vous avez raison nous nous retrouvons
nous soignant à l'hôpital dans une
situation un petit peu incongru où nous
nous occupons plus tellement de malades
mais deux personnes qu'il faut isoler et
c'est aussi ce qui nous est demandé
du reste de la population pour essayer
encore d'enrayer ce qui peut l'être
on sait que on n'échappera pas
l'épidémie en france mais gros on peut
la regarder on essaie de la retarder en
dépistant un maximum de personnes et en
isolant les positif bien entendu on est
à la limite de notre système
vous le savez l'hôpital public déjà
aller mal avant on était déjà en
sous-effectif tous un petit peu fatigué
donc ça vient rajouter tout est dans
l'urgence on s'adapte bien évidemment où
on prend en charge les personnes on se
retrouva à dépister des dizaines et
bientôt des centaines de personnes on
reçoit plus de 1000 appels par jour je
vais remporter des matchs des
scaphandres comme les chinois on voit
les photos on voit des tous les médecins
avec des scaphandres dans les
scaphandres c'est ce qu'il fout la
trouille aussi les scaphandres c'est
plutôt en laboratoire quand on manipule
directement le virus nous nous avons
évidemment des détenus avec des sur
blues avec des masques ffp2 des lunettes
des gants des charlottes des
surchaussures mais encore une fois c'est
pour éviter de
de disséminer donc voilà on se retrouve
là dans mon service par exemple avec une
vingtaine de personnes en isolement donc
ils sont pas ils sont pas spécialement
malade en tout cas elles n'ont pas de
critères d'hospitalisation mais pour
essayer de retarder la transmission
il n'y a pas dans le personnel de
soignants qui déjà vous manquer de
personnel il n'y a pas de cas déjà de
gens infectés qu'il faut retenir les cas
dans d'autres hôpitaux c'est le risque
c'est lorsqu'on a pris en charge une
personne sans savoir qu'elles étaient
contaminés et quand on l'apprend de
trois jours après ben on rappelle toutes
les personnes qui ont été amenées à s'en
occuper effectivement dans ces cas là
des personnels ont été identifiés à la
pitié aujourd'hui il n'y en a pas à ce
que je sache
mais parce que nous nous avons pris les
mesures dès l'arrivée des cas suspects
donc
et est-ce qu'on meurt du coronavirus
est-ce qu'on meure d'autres balles a dit
qu'on avait et parce qu'on attrape le
corona virus tout à coup c'est balade
ils emportent alors il semble
effectivement que des personnes qui en
meurent sont les personnes les plus
fragiles donc il ya un gradient avec
l'âge plus on est âgé plus on risque
d'en mourir à 50 ans on a une mortalité
plus élevé qu'à plus de 60 ans et à plus
de 80 ans encore plus élevés et les
enfants et et inversement les enfants
ne présenterait pas de formes sévères et
puis en plus de l'âge et à d'autres
facteurs l'obésité le diabète toujours
les mêmes le tabagisme
et puis toutes les causes
d'immunodépression donc c'est un petit
peu toujours pareil une espèce de
sélection naturelle et ce sont les plus
faibles qui succombent
[Musique]